[Music]
today's question comes from noah in
arizona i'm about to graduate from high
school i have no credit card and i was
wondering how i can prove that i can pay
my bills on time to an apartment owner
to get a lease if i haven't started any
major bills yet the only bills i pay so
far is car insurance do you have any
guidance
well hey no good on you for thinking
about that now you sound like one of our
foundation students who are getting that
stuff in order early on which is awesome
um one of the biggest things you're
going to going to want to see is your
income so i would really focus on that
early on you know they're going to want
to see a steady income history which i
know that can be hard straight out of
high school if you start working early
on maybe live somewhere with your
parents for a bit and have that income
history that's great but also look into
options like having roommates i mean you
may not qualify for an apartment
straight away if you don't have that
steady job and proof that you can pay
but you could always get a roommate
who's got a lease and you can sign on
and get a room with them so noah what's
interesting is is this is one of the
most pervasive
myths
out there
it's an absolute lie
you have to have a credit score to run
an apartment
you just don't
it's a lie
you know how we know we took one of our
ramsey personalities got them on the
phone put it on youtube and they called
27 apartment complexes and said hey i'm
moving to nashville for my first job
i don't have anything except a job i
have never borrowed any money i don't
have any credit score is that okay can i
rent an apartment there and they're like
yeah sure
do i have to do anything special
some of them said you need to put up a
little larger deposit
um
some of them said we need to see your
w-2 we need to see a you know when you
see a pay-stub from the new job
uh well i haven't ever borrowed any
money i don't have a credit score no
problem no problem
out of 27 three of them
had a problem
three it's good odds and these were like
regular apartment complexes corporate
management corporate ownership all this
stuff so this idea that you have to have
a credit score to run an apartment is
absolute bull crap
now some yeah that's true
it is harder
to rent a car with a debit card than it
is to rent an apartment with no credit
score
much harder
much harder
so this is just one of those things that
people these this mythology that people
tell we we used to call it in the legal
world they call it street law everybody
thinks they know what the law is because
they heard something one time on matlock
you know and they don't know anything
about the law but everybody then starts
to believe this myth this lie
and it's spread around you know here's
the thing noah call 20 apartment
complexes and prove me wrong
you're going to find three of them won't
let you in
and 17 of them will some of them want a
higher deposit they all want what
christina said they want proof of income
they just want to know you can pay the
bill if apartment complexes never rented
to young people doing their first job
they'd have no customers
old people that have been on the job 25
years are not in apartment complexes
people most of the time they're not the
primary customer anyway okay so
i just i kind of believed it
and then anthony o'neil that used to be
one of our personalities sat down dialed
the phone and the youtube of him die on
that phone nope nope nope nope nope it's
humorous it's so ridiculous
and it because it's one of these things
that's just widely believed to be true
that is an absolute lie
that's humorous to me
that this the emperor has no close thing
we all believe that it's this way and
we're afraid to say out loud that it's
not until you prove them with actual
data and so just just amazing so let
that myth be busted there we go pop that
puppy